alors c'est bien les fêtes tout ça le
gras le sucre l'alcool la cocaïne était
la shoah [ __ ] c'est bon c'est bon
c'est bon je me casse je me casse
bon bref vous avez abusé pendant les
fêtes
et comme tous les ans vous avez pris la
bonne résolution de vous remettre au
sport il ya quand même deux ou trois
erreurs à ne pas connaître encore
demandé à winston churchill le secret de
sa bonne santé et de sa longévité il
répondait nos sports et le fait est
qu'il est mort à 90 ans qui était pas
mal pour l'époque mais par pitié ne
faisons pas de son cas une généralité
là oui parce que le sport c'est comme
tout si c'est bien fait c'est quand même
super don pour la santé donc je ne
saurais que trop vous encourager à
reprendre le sport si vous en avez envie
bien sûr et comme je suis sympa je vais
vous donner sept conseils pour éviter
les erreurs classiques qui transforme
une bonne idée en échec voire pire fait
simple oui pour commencer et surtout qui
vous reprenez ça en solo choisissez un
sport que vous maîtrisez vous lancez pas
dans des trucs incroyables
c'est de la chine médiévale parait-il
font tout ça hollywood
[Musique]
le jogging les pompes les abdos à la
maison le fitness en salle c'est très
bien aussi
préparez bien votre reprise avant de
vous y mettre pour de bon n'hésitez pas
à renforcer un peu les muscles qui
soutiennent votre carcasse
on appelle ça des muscles posturaux être
tonique ça vous évitera pas mal de bobos
au niveau du dos par exemple le gainage
c'est pas mal ou la méthode pilates ou
toute autre technique qui fait
travailler les muscles profonds
on trouverait facilement des exercices à
faire sur le web je vous laisse chercher
la marque et julot in shape la balle est
ok je vous mets quand même quelques
liens dans la description jouga trop le
sec ou alors un autre point important
dans la préparation de votre prise
choisissez bien le moment éviter les
pics de pollution et les températures
extrêmes genre là après les fêtes il
fait moins 15 me fait plutôt du sport à
l'intérieur
ah et bien sûr vous fumez pas une heure
avant et après l'exercice minimum fumer
ça fait baisser le taux d'oxygène dans
notre organisme et la nicotine ça
accélère le rythme cardiaque et ça c'est
bon ni pour vos muscles ni pour vos
coeurs bon allez cette fois c'est bon
vous avez mis votre licra le plus fluo
et vos organes génitaux sont mauvais
comme jamais avant de commencer et
chauffée vous oui tout le monde le sait
mais personne ne le fait donc
pourtant ça sert ni plus ni moins qu'à
préparer à l'effort ses muscles ses
articulations mais aussi son coeur et
même son esprit tout ça en douceur ce
qui évite les traumatismes et les
accidents échauffez vous une dizaine de
minutes minimum surtout si vous faites
du sport le matin ou après une grande
période d'inactivité et surtout s'il
fait froid
hydratez-vous et manger correctement
quand vous faites du sport votre
température corporelle augmenter votre
organisme met en place une parade pour
lutter contre la surchauffe
la transpiration elle peut vous faire
perdre entre 500 millilitres et 2 litre
et demi d'eau par heure ça dépend de
l'intensité de votre effort et il se
trouve que l'os est le principal
composant notre corps puisqu'elle
représente entre 60 et 70 % de son poids
total en manquer ça diminue vos
performances et ça augmente le risque de
crampes de tendinites et de blessure et
quand vous sortez la soif c'est déjà
trop tard à lampe uv régulièrement avant
et pendant l'exercice et après aussi
tant qu'on y est ah oui mais bon j'ai
bien compris on va y avoir une histoire
de régime aussi là dessous mais faites
attention diminuer les graisses ok
diminuer les sucres rapides genre les
bonbons les desserts d'accord et votre
corps il a besoin de carburant
1 surtout pour faire du sport et
notamment de sucres lents de fibres et
de protéines
alors allez-y reposez-vous se dépenser
c'est bien mais les phases de
récupération c'est important pour
permettre à vos muscles de se développer
et aussi pour leur permettre de se
remettre de l'effort et donc d'éviter
les blessures
après chaque séance prenez le temps de
vous étirer et ne fait pas du sport tous
les jours
gardez-vous quelques jours de repos dans
la semaine surtout au début et dormait
fait des vrais nuit de sommeil
allez-y progressivement si vous avez
déjà fait du sport vous étiez peut-être
habitué à courir une heure et demie ou à
soulever soit 100 kg au développé couché
mais c'était il ya longtemps et votre
organisme bas il a perdu l'habitude la
force et l'endurance ça se perd donc
ayez l'humilité de repartir plus bas que
là où vous aviez arrêté qui vous êtes
complètement noob fait pas les foules
ont commencé par un petit footing de
reprise de 15 minutes
la fois suivante vous passez à 20
minutes et vous augmentez
progressivement jusqu'à la durée que
vous avez envie d'atteindre et après
vous êtes montré votre vitesse
si vous faites du sport en salle
commencé avec des charges légères et des
séries avec peu de répétitions puis
augmentez progressivement en plus ça
vous évitera de vous décourager ou de
vous dégoûter vaut mieux commencer petit
augmenter progressivement et s'inscrire
dans la durée pour finir de vous
convaincre d'y aller doucement sachez
que dans certains cas trop de sport d'un
coup ça peut tuer sans même parler des
problèmes cardiaques
là on parle de l'arabe de miollis
l'arabe de miollis c'est une destruction
des fibres musculaires
elle peut arriver si un membre reste
compris mais trop longtemps mais aussi
après un effort musculaire trop intense
ou trop prolongée on appelle ça une
rhabdomyolyse d'efforts et s'est
aggravée par une hydratation
insuffisante
attention là on parle pas de 20 minutes
de jogging ou dix pompes à eau vraiment
forcer
l'exemple typique c'est la jeune recrue
militaire à qui on fait faire un
entraînement intensif pendant toute une
journée et cas pas le droit de s'arrêter
même s'il a des douleurs oui parce que
ça fait mal mais ça peut aussi toucher
ceux qui font des courses d'endurance
très longue genre sur plusieurs jours il
ya aussi des cas qui ont été rapportés
chez des amateurs de crossfit qui se
passe c'est que le muscle est tellement
traumatisée par les forts que les fibres
musculaires sont détruites et que les
substances produites par leurs
dégradations se retrouve dans la
circulation sanguine et notamment la
myoglobine qui est toxique pour les
reins qui peuvent se bloquer
parallèlement le taux de potassium
augmente dans le sang
on appelle ça une hypercalcémie les
reins ne peuvent plus l'éliminer
puisqu'ils sont bloqués et ça peut
provoquer un arrêt cardiaque
bon ça c'est des cas graves est extrême
ok avant d'en arriver là il ya des
signes qui pousse l'immense majorité des
gens à arrêter ce qu'ils sont en train
de faire genre un coup de fatigue ou des
grosses douleurs
ce qui nous amène directement au conseil
suivant écoutez votre corps
et oui pour éviter les ennuis du plus
grave au plus petit restez à l'écouté de
votre corps
oui j'ai préféré fin j'ai faim j'ai faim
j'ai faim j'ai faim j'ai faim j'ai faim
j'ai l'estomac
enfin j'ai faim j'ai faim j'ai on peut
se tutoyer oui assez l'anus du jour
jamais de blagues en fait c'est bien
d'écouter tout le monde mais il ya
surtout une chose à laquelle il faut
être très attentif
oui bonjour c'est la douleur la douleur
c'est un signal d'alarmé qui dit
attention il se passe quelque chose de
pas bon là donc soyez attentif si vous
avez mal
arrêtez vous et si la douleur persiste
mettez-vous au repos et consulté remise
à est d'ailleurs puisqu'on en parle
si vous avez passé la quarantaine et que
vous n'avez pas fait de sport depuis un
petit moment
bah votre médecin rendez lui une petite
visite avant de commencer il vous
proposera peut-être un test d'effort
c'est à dire observez votre activité
cardiaque pendant une activité sportive
genre courir sur un tapis ou faire du
vélo
déconnez pas avec votre coeur
pendant les séances en cas de douleur ou
de sensations de malaise
arrêtez tous et par les autres mecs mais
il ya des signes qui doit vous faire
réagir beaucoup plus si vous ressentez
une douleur dans la poitrine alors ça
sert si ça ira du dans le bras dans la
mâchoire ou dans le dos si vous êtes
essoufflé de façon brutale arrêté la
séance et fait appeler le 15
c'est peut-être rien mais si vous faites
un infarctus le salut va débouler il va
commencer à vous soigner sur place et ça
va vous faire gagner de précieuses
minutes bonfi peppard que tu ne servait
pas de ça comme excuse pour pas faire de
sport
si vous suivez ces conseils si vous
faites les choses bien il y aura pas de
soucis tu es tu as là bas nous faire du
bien parce qu'une activité physique
régulière ça permet d'éviter les
infarctus d'ailleurs churchill est en
affaires alors nos spots voit la dtcc
fini pour aujourd'hui on se retrouve
très vite pour une nouvelle vidéo
d'ici là tenez vos bonnes résolutions
mettez vous bien et surtout portez vous
bien
[Musique]